c'est un pas vers une sortie de crise un
accord conclu entre les différentes
forces politiques géorgiennes après des
mois marqué par les divisions secoué par
d'importantes manifestations à la suite
des législatives de l'automne dernier
remportées par le parti au pouvoir mais
truqué selon l'opposition
la géorgie pourrait enfin retrouver un
horizon politique dégagé sa 4s en
signant ce document aujourd'hui la
géorgie fait un pas en avant vers
l'europe
c'est pourquoi j'ai décidé de le signer
aussi je dois mentionner que ce document
est une voie pour mettre fin aux
poursuites politiques dans notre pays et
libérer les prisonniers politiques
à votre avis aux fautes allez salut est
venu chauny dray c'est un jour très
important qui lie au renforcement de la
démocratie en géorgie et les réformes
démocratiques fondamentales que nous
avons mené avec un citoyen et les
partenaires à nous donne la possibilité
d'avoir un parlement multipartite et
représenta da à un accord supervisé par
bruxelles qui a voulu se présenter en
médiateur de cette crise pour le
président du conseil européen charles
michel ce pacte constitue je cite un
point de départ vers la consolidation de
la démocratie géorgienne hybrid tout et
new chapter je pense que le chapitre ou
d'aujourd'hui est particulièrement
important dans le contexte régional
difficile
c'est une région confrontée à de
nombreux défis comme le haut karabagh
bangla douloureusement rappelé l'année
dernière tout aujourd'hui le
renforcement militaire le long des
frontières de l'ukraine et en crimée
illégalement annexée est très
préoccupante la façon dont vous avez
abordé l'un passe aujourd'hui est
particulièrement crucial dans ce
contexte régional
c'est véritablement une manière
européenne de résoudre la crise l'europe
nous et le mouvement national uni
principale force d'opposition a précisé
que sa signature reste soumise à
l'application d'un point négocier dans
le texte la libération de son
leaders emprisonnés ni camélia le parti
qui organisera une nouvelle
manifestation anti gouvernementale le 15
mai prochain